[scats]
(all)
♪ There goes the girl
who owns my heart ♪
♪ I knew she was the one
right from the start ♪
- ♪ Ooh-wah
- ♪ Our love is here to stay
- ♪ Each and every day
♪ We know that we will
never part ♪
[scats]
(Lyle)
Oh, wow.
Great work, everybody.
Troy, I love that little
Motown outro thing.
Super soulful.
Cool.
Thanks, Lyle.
Yeah, it just, uh, came to me,
so I went with it.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Hey, is this where
the a cappella group meets?
- Oh, hey, Mark.
- Hey, Lyle.
What's going on, buddy?
- Mark, get over here.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(Lyle)
Guys, this is my buddy, Mark.
He just transferred
from Minnesota.
I thought he could sit in
on a few practices.
I don't know,
maybe join the group?
Maybe.
[chuckles]
(Lyle)
All right, guys.
Let's do "Always Been My Girl"
again, from the top.
- "Always Been My Girl," okay.
- And...Mark?
- Show us your stuff.
- You got it, man.
- (Lyle)
All right, guys.
Ready?
- One, two...
- [scats]
(all)
♪ There goes the girl
♪ Who owns my heart
♪ I knew she was the one
right from the start ♪
- ♪ Ooh wah
- ♪ Our love is here to stay
- ♪ Each and every day
♪ We know that we will
never part ♪
[scats]
♪ Ooh-wee-ee-ooh
[all laugh and clap]
(Lyle)
You got to be kidding me.
Mark, that was
out of this world.
Oh, gosh, okay, well, hey,
it just came to me,
so I just went with it.
(Lyle)
Great.
Well, keep going with it.
Guys, have a safe weekend,
all right?
- See you on Monday.
- Nice to meet you guys, man.
- That was awesome.
- Isn't he the best?
Cool, guys.
Great practice.
- Troy, good effort.
- All right.
[Troy laughs]
Yeah, check you later, guys.
See you later, alligators.
[ominous music]
♪
The fuck you think
you doing, nigga?
I'm doing my thing, nigga.
The fuck you doing?
See...
this is my seven white boys,
nigga.
- [scoffs]
- You need to back the fuck up.
Fuck that, nigga.
I'm 'bouts to get mine.
Do you have any idea
how long it took
for me to infiltrate
this group, nigga?
25 minutes.
You think I'm gonna
roll over
for some falsetto-ass
motherfucker?
[scoffs]
Well, you know what, nigga?
White boys is gonna do
what white boys is gonna do.
And if they want to run with a
high-ass-singing falsetto nigga,
then that's on them.
Oh, that's on them, then?
Oh, that's on them,
then.
Okay, so it's like that?
Oh, it's so
like that.
Well, watch your back, nigga!
- Okay.
- Watch your back, nigga!
'Cause you fuck
with my shit,
I'll fuck with your shit,
nigga!
[echoing]
(man)
And improvise.
Oh, it's so cold out,
and it's going to be dark soon.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, we should build a fire.
Right, yeah, um, like...
Oh! Fire! Fire!
Freeze!
Oh, no.
It's a black cat.
Hey, man.
Why the cat
got to be black?
[laughter]
Freeze!
[dramatic music]
♪
Man, I guess I got to put
my dick away.
[laughter]
[suspenseful music]
♪